If you ask a hipster, the word hipster has pretty much lost all meaning,
but if you ask someone else,
it means a hipster and everybody gets it.
[INTRO MUSIC]
Hey there friends!
Grab your fancy coffees. I'm Trace.
Thanks for watching DNews.
Slide into those skinny jeans, grab the deepest-v you got and hop on your fixie,
because we're going where everyone
seems to go: down hipster lane.
Hipsters are difficult to describe as a group, but we know one when we see one, right?
And a new mathematical neuroscience paper explains why that is.
"The hipster effect: When anticonformists all look the same,"
focuses specifically on French hipsters. Their results found that hipsters, they can't even hipster.
Seriously! According to their math, which
looks like this, hipsters are too slow to change
and the reason all hipsters look alike, is because they are all part of the mainstream pretty much right away.
The paper says because the hipsters are too
slow to react to new trends, they continue
to make the same choices -- a la wearing a beard, dark-rim glasses, plaid -- which maintains a correlation
to each other and thus the opposite of the
contrarian culture.
Essentially hipsters become a group on their own.
A separate study in the Journal of Consumer
Research in 2010 found that, normally,
people don't just purchase products, they purchase
the emotion behind those products too.
So buying a Jeep you'll feel rugged, or Lululemon will help you feel powerful in the gym or something.
Hipsters, on the other hand, purchase
things that run counter to their emotional
interest -- like PBR.
Their study say that hipsters are confounding for marketers
because they purchase things that they actually hate,
then subconsciously convince themselves they're not part of the trend that's bad.
It doesn't reflect who they really are, man.
According to Psychology Today's
report on the study, "the essence of being
a hipster [is] pretending you aren't one."
Which is super interesting if you think about
it, because this new math study sort of vogues
with their assessment. The researchers also
determined the ability of a hipster to see
the trend of wearing plaid or a beard or something,
is more difficult the closer they
are to another hipster.
For example, two people in the same friend group
won't see themselves as alike because even
though they're both wearing vintage high-school,
sports-team t-shirts they got at Goodwill,
a stranger at a coffee shop would notice it right away, and they wouldn't
The further you are from the system in question, the easier it is to spot the correlation.
Plus, the science of the hipster isn't just
limited to clothes and trends, there's also
huge music scenes associated with counterculture.
A service called Priceonomics used data from
Facebook in congress with a music blog called Pitchfork,
to determine how underground, and therefore hipster, a band could be.
It was pretty accurate for 2013. Bands like Sun Kil Moon and The Field were considered very hipster.
They had lots of critical acclaim, but very few shares
and mentions on a giant social network, Facebook,
while Vampire Weekend was only a teeny bit hipster
because people shared it way too often. Way too pop culture, guys.
Justin Timberlake? Not hipster in the least.
Science, yo.
Trends exist throughout pop culture, and because
hipsters buy a lot of stuff, researchers are
looking at their habits and social structures.
Interestingly, hipster is thought to be
someone who attempts a specific counterculture,
but in reality it does fit more with the dictionary
definition, "a person who follows the latest
trends and fashions."
At least, according to this math study.
So with that, I say, the v-neck/moustache
combo is just the 20-teens version
of the Starter Jacket or parachute pants or big, feathered hair found in other decades.
It was counterculture for a minute, and then
everyone started doing it, so it wasn't anymore.
The counterculture becomes the culture so fast,
according to mathematics, that people can't adapt quick enough.
In the end, people who try to
fight a trend, are copying other people, and
are therefore part of a trend.
Are you a hipster? Say it. Be proud! Go ahead down at the comments. Let us know.
If not, just tell us your favorite hipster spotting story because we've all got one.
Go ahead and subscribe to DNews while you're at it and thanks for watching.